- Hey, come on in.
(bouncy keyboard music)
Yes, push and
believe, you got it.
Jonah Ray.
- Brody Stevens.
- You got it,
Steven Brody Stevens
if you so choose to go that
way, but you don't have to.
- I don't want to.
- So you've, ow, I
hit my elbow, darn it.
I hit my elbow, and where
is the nearest hospital?
Let me check the call sheet.
- I think you should
just wait a little bit,
I think the pain might go away.
- You gotta be
feeling good, Jonah.
- I feel okay, I'm
getting married.
- Yeah, you're getting married.
- Yeah.
- Where is that gonna
happen, Comic-Con?
We had a Twitter tiff
regarding the tsunami,
the great tsunami of Japan,
and I went on Twitter
and I made a joke about,
can somebody check my mail
before the tsunami
hits my condominium.
It got 17 retweets, and
then you went on Twitter,
and you said, 'Brody,'
'cause you're from Hawaii,
like that was a real,
the tsunami could've
impacted Honolulu.
- Yes it was headed
for Honolulu.
- No joke.
- Parents are there,
they live near the water.
- And you said, at
Brodyismefriend,
'Brody, shut the fuck up.'
- Is that all I said?
- Yes.
- Really?
- Maybe you had,
do you remember?
- I'm out of my mind, I can't
get a hold of my parents,
when I finally do, my dad
says they're just gonna stay
and wait it out,
I'm going crazy.
And then I saw your tweet,
I could've easily just
emailed or texted you,
but for some reason I
did it in a public forum,
and it was not cool of me.
- Really?
- Yeah, I think that's a
silly thing that I did,
I regretted doing it.
- I'm not gonna say
I held a grudge,
but it was something
I thought about,
now I feel so much better,
I got it off of my chest,
you got it off your chest.
- Well, it wasn't on my chest.
- It wasn't?
- No I hadn't really thought
about either of those tweets
since the moment they happened.
- I let it go now
once I heard you say
it was wrong and you
felt bad about it.
- You let it go when I
put the blame on myself.
- Yes.
- Yeah so when I was
like it was my fault,
you were like oh this
is such a relief.
- Right.
Thank you very much,
Jonah, you're a good sport,
Johan Ray, he's got an
album, he's got a podcast,
and he's got a pilot, and
it's gonna get picked up.
- Ooh, is it?
This is great news!
I'm gonna call everyone
I know and tell them
that Brody said my
pilot got picked up.
Mom, I can get us
out of trouble.
- Get to high ground.
Yes, what a great video,
it's inspired me to exercise,
it should inspire you to
click and subscribe and like
and even tweet at me,
whoo, feeling good.
Laughter makes me exercise,
yes, you got it,
push and believe.